[Applaus]
[Musik]
eines müssen uns klarmachen fossile
brennstoffe sind nicht gerade mit mode
eigentlich wären sie seit geraumer zeit
geradezu verdammt und fast täglich
finden regierungen vieler großer länder
rund um den erdball neue regeln
vorschriften finanzielle belastungen und
zur regionen um die energiewende
voranzutreiben
japans grüne ambitionen bedrohen den
markt für flüssigerdgas den es mit
aufgebaut hat japans aggressiver neuer
plan sich für saubere energie
einzusetzen erschüttert den markt für
flüssigerdgas bei 2,25 billionen dollar
infrastruktur planen wird sich auf grüne
energie und dekarbonisierung
konzentrieren dieser krieg der regierung
hingegen fossile brennstoffe wird
natürlich unglaublich abschreckend auf
investoren und die gesamte industrie die
investitionsaktivitäten öl und
gasindustrie befindet sich auf ein
15-jahrestief
bericht waren vor globaler energiekrise
wenn höhere investitionen in öl und gas
ausbleiben knappheit könnte höhere
kraftstoffpreise mehr energie armut und
einen anstieg der treibhausgasemissionen
bedeuten es ist zu spät um eine größere
öl versorgungskrise zu vermeiden
[Musik]
so wie es aussieht sind wir weniger als
30 jahre davon entfernt die von vielen
ländern darunter auch die der
europäischen union gesetzte frist für
die vollständige dekarbonisierung zu
erreichen ein weiteres land welches sich
für das jahr 2050 das ziel gesetzt hat
kein co2 mehr mädchen ist südkorea
ein land das die aufgabe eine wirklich
realisierbaren dekarbonisierung plan zu
entwerfen und umzusetzen sehr ernst
nimmt südkorea erhebt hierbei jedoch den
anspruch dass dieser plan nicht nur
irgendwie technisch machbar sein wird
sondern vor allem den geldbeutel seiner
bürger schonen soll klingt wie aus einer
anderen welt nicht war zu schön um wahr
zu sein aber passt auf den der reden
hier nicht über irgendein land südkorea
ist ein industrielles kraftzentrum oder
sieht größte emittent von treibhausgasen
auf diesen planeten von den insgesamt
emittierten treibhausgasen stammen rund
86 prozent aus dem energiesektor und
energie braucht die koreanische
industrie wie die sprichwörtliche luft
zum atmen tatsächlich werden 55 prozent
der südkorea verbrauchte energie vom
industriesektor verbraucht das ist der
höchste anteil aller mitgliedsländer der
internationalen energieagentur eine
weitere tatsache 98 prozent der
emissionen der südkoreanischen
energiesektor aus werbung durch die
verbrennung fossiler brennstoffe
verursacht
und das ist kein wunder bei der
stromerzeugung zum beispiel produziert
südkorea heute noch fast 40 prozent
seines stroms durch die verbrennung von
kohle und weitere 27 prozent durch
erdgas mit seiner abhängigkeit von
fossilen brennstoffen insgesamt steht
südkorea damit ziemlich weit an der
weltspitze wenn wir den energiesektor um
alle anderen produktiven aktivitäten wie
verkehrs- und transportwesen
berücksichtigen südkoreas wirtschaft
baut heutzutage nun mal fast vollständig
aus der verbrennung fossiler brennstoffe
auf die vollständige dekarbonisierung
des landes bis 2050 scheint in einem
solchen szenario eher eine schimäre zu
sein vielmehr reines wunschdenken als
eine realistische option
umso mehr wenn man bedenkt dass die
derzeitige regierung auch die
kernenergie aufs korn nehmen will die
frage die wir uns alle stellen können
lautet also wie um himmels willen will
südkorea seine ziele erreichen verfügt
die regierung von präsidentin über eine
zauberformel oder ist einfach nur ein
schaumschläger der keine ahnung vom
tuten und blasen hatte sowie viele
politiker heutzutage nun weißt du was
man hat kürzlich einen vorschlag mit
drei verschiedenen möglichen strategien
vorgelegt hast du dich jemals gefragt ob
es möglich ist mit kohle oder erdgas
energie zu erzeugen ohne die umwelt zu
verschmutzen auch wenn das wie science
fiction klingt die idee existiert und
mehr noch an ihrer umsetzung wird
bereits gearbeitet zumindest behauptet
dass die regierung nun also aufgepasst
longines energie traum
[Musik]
wenn südkorea seine abhängigkeit von
schmutziger energie verringern und
gleichzeitig seine mächtige industrie
nicht lähmen oder schädigen will müssen
die südkoreaner verdammt die
einfallsreichtum an den tag legen genau
aus diesem grund hat die regierung neben
einer multi millionen dollar strategie
an allen fronten auch drei mögliche
pläne zur anpassung des energiesektors
anders 0 kohlenstoff szenario konkret
vorgestellt drei plänen über die nun
diskutiert werden muss der erste dieser
pläne sieht vor dass das land einige
seiner kohle und erdgaskraftwerke
praktisch unbegrenzte zumindest so lange
weiter betreibt bis sie vollständig
abgeschrieben sind dazu würden sie eine
neue technik zur abscheidung nutzung und
speicherung von kohlenstoff einsetzen
bekannt unter ihrem englischen akronym
us für kabel capture and storage und ja
ich weiß was du jetzt denkst aber mag
was soll bitte schön neu seien an
kohlenstoffabscheidung das gibt es
anderswo schon längst ja du hast recht
aber ein sehr wichtiges das zählt bisher
wurden diese techniken noch nicht
eingesetzt um emissionen wirklich großen
maßstab zu erfassen so was rentabel zu
betreiben wäre an sich schon etwas neues
und nach schätzungen der südkoreanischen
regierung wird der einsatz dieser
technik zusammen mit der von wasserstoff
über den wir auf diese politik
gesprochen haben sowie elektroautos und
erneuerbaren energien dem land
ermöglichen bis 2050 mehr als 95 trotz
seiner co2 emission zu eliminieren
ohne seine industrielle
wettbewerbsfähigkeit übermäßig belasten
zu müssen oder zu gewähren
der zweite plan sieht vor die kohle
vollständig aus der stromerzeugung zu
verbannen aber flüssig erdgas als
flexible energiequelle zur deckung des
bedarfs beizubehalten natürlich würde
die kohle durch regenerative
energieträger ersetzt werden und
schließlich wäre da der dritte plan der
strengste und kostspieligste würde er
angenommen könnte das land bis 2050
vollständig aus der nutzung von kohle
und erdgas aussteigen diese
energiequellen würden durch erneuerbare
energieträger und grünen wasserstoff
ersetzt werden dieser plan würde es
ermöglichen das sogenannte null
kohlenstoff szenario zu erreichen aber
er wäre natürlich am teuersten in der
umsetzung nun das kuriose an diesen drei
vorschlägen ist dass in allen drei
szenarien die atomkraft weiterhin eine
wichtige rolle spielen obwohl
präsidenten eigentlich den atomausstieg
befürwortet dessen regierung hat zwar
vor den anteil der kernenergie am
südkoreanischen strommix allmählich zu
reduzieren aber sie geht nicht über
leichen das heißt sie wollen deswegen
kein geld verbrennen und investitionen
vernichten und da es im land mehrerer so
gut wie völlig neue reaktoren gibt sich
sogar einige weitere im bau befinden
wollen sie die kernenergie frühestens im
jahr 2000 83 vollständig abschaffen und
bis dahin kann sich ja noch so einiges
ändern so und jetzt fragst du dich
sicher welche dieser drei strategie
eigentlich im augenblick der favorit ist
nun das ist kein großes geheimnis es ist
die erste mit anderen worten selbst im 0
kohlenstoff szenario würde ein teil des
stroms immer noch mit schmutzigen
energieträgern erzeugt werden daher
lautet die preisfrage um die sich alles
dreht welches potenzial steckt wirklich
in der kohlenstoffabscheidung wieder die
südkoreanische regierung die aus
schmutzigen brennstoff im gewohnten
energie in saubere energie umwandelt
könnte südkorea zum weltmarktführer für
sauber oder nicht erneuerbare energie
werden entsteht hier eine wirkliche
alternative nun genau das verraten wir
euch jetzt
[Musik]
speicher unter tage
was eine wenig bekannte tatsache ist
südkorea könnte bei der umsetzung der
kohlenstoffabscheidung und -speicherung
für die stromerzeugung einen erheblichen
vorteil gegenüber anderen ländern haben
wir haben es dabei mit einer
kostspieligen technik zu tun die im jahr
2020 weltweit den ausstoß von 40
millionen tonnen co2 in die atmosphäre
verhindert hat nun das mag wie eine
riesige menge klingen bis man erfährt
dass jedes jahr weltweit etwa 35
milliarden tonnen co2 ausgestoßen werden
wir sprechen hier also von einer
emissionsreduktion um sage und schreibe
1 promille und das für ein schweinegeld
was person ebenfalls südkoreas diesem
sessel fuß vorhaben zum durchbruch
verhelfen nun sieh dir mal kurz dieses
bild an
was wird da sehe sieht auf den ersten
blick aus wie eine weitere
förderplattform für erdgas aber darunter
verbirgt sich der neueste energie jogger
des südkoreanischen regierung die rede
ist vom erdgasfeld dem g1 im japanischen
meer um dessen namen des übrigens schon
seit 30 jahren einen erbitterten streit
gibt denn die koreaner bestehen auf
dessen umbenennungen auf internationalen
karten in koreanisches meer ostmeer oder
koreanisches oft mehr über weitere
dieser reibereien mit japan haben wir
übrigens vor kurzem in einem anderen
video berichtet du kannst es dir über
den link oben rechts oder in der
beschreibung zu diesem video ansehen und
falls unseren kanal noch nicht abonniert
hat dann macht das jetzt schnell und
aktiviere auch das kleine glöckchen
damit auch in zukunft unsere spannen
videos nicht mehr verpasst aber zurück
zu unseren erdgasfeld dem g1
dieses feld wird 2022 stillgelegt und
die koreaner haben die idee bereits
existierende pipeline zur küste für den
transport von co2 aus kohle und erdgas
kraftwerken unter den meeresgrund zu
nutzen so plant die südkoreanische
regierung den lehre unterirdischen raum
zu nutzen um die umweltschädlichen gase
die bei der stromerzeugung entstehen in
das alte erdgasfeld einzuleiten und ich
weiß ganz genau was ist viele von euch
denken mag das klingt doch verdammt
gefährlich solche geologischen
experimente enden doch meist in einer
riesigen katastrophe
tja das scheint ein weit verbreitetes
vorurteil zu sein denn der
wissenschaftliche konsens ist ganz
anderer ansicht laut communiqué und
seines zeichens auch besser für geo
umweltwissenschaften an der konsum
national university würde das auffüllen
von treibhausgasen in der bereits
geförderte erdgas quelle die
ideologische stabilität des gebiets
sogar verbessern und bei näherer
betrachtung ist dies ja eigentlich ganz
logisch vorher befand sich ja schon eine
menge gas unter dem meeresboden welches
um abgesaugt wurde sodass dort druck
gesetzt man es durch ein anderes gas
wird wieder der natürliche zustand
wieder hergestellt das hier ist
natürlich keineswegs das erste mal dass
so etwas vorgeschlagen wird aber das
südkoreanische projekt scheint ein
bisschen das ehrgeizigste und auch das
machbar zu sein nach schätzungen
südkoreanischer experten auf diesem
gebiet könnte das land bis zum jahr 2025
etwa 400.000 tonnen treibhausgase pro
jahr oder erde spielfeld nori 1
speichern
und das wäre erst der anfang südkorea
behauptet das ist bis 2023 dank der
bereits laufenden forschungen die
kapazität haben wird jährlich vier
millionen tonnen co2 speichern schau dir
mal diesen karte an
die beiden roten punkte steht für die
beiden anlagen zur
kohlenstoffabscheidung die derzeit als
pilotprojekte dienen das sind pro jong
chol und hd daneben gibt es zwei weitere
potenzielle standorte an denen in
zukunft co2 speicher in betrieb genommen
werden aber moment mal wir wollen hier
nicht zu weit vorgreifen denn worüber
wir noch nicht gesprochen haben ist die
kohle also ich meine jetzt das geld den
zaster schätzungen gehen davon aus dass
die abschaltung einer tonne co2 mit
bestehende technologie zwischen 60 und
70 us-dollar pro tonne kosten würde
damit diese technik aber im rahmen der
stromerzeugung sinnvoll eingesetzt
werden kann ohne dass den südkoreanern
astronomische stromrechnungen ist haus
flattern müssten die kosten pro tonne
auf maximal 30 us-dollar gesenkt werden
und bis dahin ist es noch ein weiter weg
denn um co2 speicherung wirklich
rentabel zu machen werden die
südkoreaner noch viel in forschung und
entwicklung investieren müssen
aber selbst wenn ihm dies eines tages
gelingen sollte würde es sich dabei im
rahmen der aktuellen pläne immer noch um
eine marginale lösung handeln nicht um
eine echte alternative
denn selbst wenn dieser plan erfolgreich
ist würde das erreichen der 0
kohlenstoff htg bedeuten dass mindestens
90 prozent der energiequellen sauber
sein müssten und an diesem punkt
angekommen sagen sich viele von euch mag
hast du es nicht die koreanische energie
wunderwaffe versprochen aber diese ganze
pläne die die uns hier vorgestellt hast
sind nichts anderes als flickwerk
[Musik]
kommt jetzt noch was was ist denn zum
beispiel mit der atomkraft nun das ist
eine gute frage und ich danke dir dafür
also kernenergie ist ja bekanntlich co2
neutral will ich und was noch wichtiger
ist eine kernkompetenz der südkoreaner
südkorea ist eine der größten
atomenergie mächte der welt verfügt über
jede menge know-how hervorragende
wissenschaftler forschungseinrichtungen
und patente mit ihrer fortschrittlichen
technologie sind die südkoreaner spielt
in der lage kernreaktor der dritten
generation zu entwickeln herzustellen
und sogar zu exportieren warum also
kehren sie der energie der atome den
rücken zu nur hier kommt wieder die
politik ins spiel aufgepasst
[Musik]
ausgegrenzte energie
hast du schon mal was die atomkraft
moratorium gehört nun es ist genau das
was sich seit einiger zeit ein paar
europäischen ländern abspielt ein
atomkraft moratorium bedeutet wörtlich
dass der bau neuer atomkraftwerke und
reaktoren verboten ist in deutschland
und spanien sind zum beispiel solche
moratorien in kraft nun im fall von
südkorea gibt es kein moratorium aber
die regierung von userinnen schmiedet
seit ihrem amtsantritt pläne für ein
ende der atomkraft
2017 südkoreas präsident plant den
ausstieg aus der atomenergie und das
eine große welle der empörung ausgelöst
warum nun weil es sich bei südkorea
obwohl es auf eine halb eins liegt in
wirklichkeit um eine vollkommene energie
insel handelt da südkorea im norden an
nordkorea grenzt und in den übrigen
himmelsrichtungen und mehr ist günstig
koreaner kein strom aus drittländern
importieren sie müssen also
sicherstellen dass ich völlig autark
sind und nicht nur das sie müssen autark
und
wettbewerbsfähig sein
[Musik]
genau aus diesem grund ist das
engagement der südkoreaner für die
kernenergie historisch gesehen sehr
wichtig so dass das land nach den usa
frankreich china und russland nummer
fünf der weltrangliste ist was die
anzahl der in betrieb befindlichen
kernreaktoren angeht insgesamt 24 stück
zusammen können sie mehr als 23 gigawatt
strom erzeugen was etwa 26 prozent des
nationalen strom access entspricht
außerdem verfügt südkorea über die
höchste dichte an atomreaktoren der welt
das heißt der höchste anzahl in
reaktoren auf kleinsten raum wir
sprechen hier von nicht weniger als 24
reaktoren die sich auch nur vier
kraftwerke verteilen
[Musik]
die cam energie erfordert zwar hohe
anfangsinvestitionen aber dafür bietet
sie saubere billige und stabile
energielieferung was für länder wie
südkorea die von reporten und
schwankenden weltmarktpreisen für
energie abhängig sind von enormem
vorteil ist tatsächlich sind die 30 die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit und die
versorgungssicherheit unter stabilen
bedingungen für die unternehmens
faktoren die den industriellen und
wirtschaftlichen aufschwungs südkorea
seit jahren gefördert haben trotzdem
veranlasste die angst dass sich die
fukushima katastrophe ist südkorea
irgendwie wiederholen könnte man dazu in
seinem wahlkampf 2017 zu versprechen
dass er sich für den ausstieg aus der
atomkraft einsetzen würde natürlich
erscheint dies vielen politischen und
wirtschaftlichen akteuren im land wie
ein haufen unsinn
wie man jedoch durch einen kurzen blick
in die geschichte schnell feststellen
kann gibt es nun mal keine aber auch
rein gar keine gesetzmäßigkeit nach der
politik auch nur irgendeinen sinn
ergeben muss und so wurde im und 2017
zum präsidenten gewählt aber nächstes
jahr also für 2022 stehen erneut
präsidentschaftswahlen an die
konservativen haben gute chancen das
blaue haus das südkoreanische äquivalent
zum weißen haus zurück zu erobern und
wisst ihr was den position in sachen
atomkraft ist sehr sehr eindeutig
atomausstiegsplan wird zum
schlüsselthema bei den kommenden
präsidentschaftswahlen der zudem der
widerstand gegen den atomausstieg der
regierung hat präsidentschaftskandidaten
aus dem oppositionsblock dazu veranlasst
die wiederaufnahme der nutzung der
kernenergie zu versprechen und dabei zu
betonen dass sie die billigste und
sauberste alternative zu fossilen
brennstoffen in korea seit welches zur
deckung seines erdöl bedarfs vollständig
auf importe angewiesen ist mit anderen
worten trotz aller aktuellen pläne ist
ist nicht unvernünftig so denken dass
die südkoreanische antwort auf null
kohlenstoff am ende der kernenergie sein
rad wie du siehst scheinen die anderen
optionen entweder sehr kostspielig und
unsicher oder direkt nicht machbar zu
sein auch wenn noch so sehr mit dem fuß
auf den boden stampft und auf dem
gegenteil beharrt die frage lautet also
sollten jene länder welche bereits aus
der kernkraft ausgestiegen sind diese
unter den veränderten umständen wieder
als realistische option zur erzeugung
großer menge saubere energie anerkennen
bevor das vorstellt antwortest sie dazu
erstmal diese meldung an china wird den
ersten uran freien atomreaktor der welt
in betrieb dem das asiatische land wird
im september mit der erprobung seines
thorium und flüssiger als kernkraftwerks
beginn dieser reaktortyp ist theoretisch
viel sicherer als die derzeit in betrieb
befindlichen werden die chinesen zu den
neuen anführern der kernkraft oder eine
der anderen staaten welche gerne
reaktoren der vierten generation
vorantreiben da wären russland
frankreich die usa großbritannien
australien kanada japan natürlich
südkorea und sogar südafrika und die
kleine schweiz nun dieses ganze thema
wurde der umfang dieses videos bei
weitem sprengen daher werden wir es in
weiteren videos aufgreifen und
detailliert auseinander nehmen also noch
ein grund visual politik zu abonnieren
den atomreaktoren der vierten generation
sind eine unglaublich faszinierendes
thema sie sind der große game changer
was die sicherheit und
umweltverträglichkeit der kernenergie
angeht denn diese reaktoren können sogar
den radioaktiven abfall der älteren
kraftwerke nutzen und zu isotopen mit
relativ kurzen zerfalls zeiten
verbrennen so dass eine endlagerung kein
großes problem mehr darstellt viele
atomkraftgegner werden kritik in der
vergangenheit sicher einen großen teilen
berechtigt war werden die urteile nun
gegenüber genf vier reaktoren von grund
auf überdenken müssen denn wenn die
politik es will können diese auch zum
großen game changer der gesamten
energiewende werden schließlich ist mit
ihnen eine zukunft ohne co2 emissionen
denkbar die nicht in einem finanziellen
und wirtschaftlichen harakiri aus achtet
was meinst du dazu welche staaten haben
hier die besseren karten und welche
strategie sollte dein land verfolgen
teile deine meinung bitte wir immer mit
uns und auch allen anderen im
kommentarbereich ich hoffe dass dieses
video gefallen hat falls ja gib uns
bitte einen leckeren teils auch mit
deinen freunden machs gut und bis bald
[Musik]